Kyle schwarber the Chicago Cubs what a
great story he was got injured early in
the season game two blew out his knee
and then had to go through rehab the
entire year
and all of a sudden you started to hear
rumblings that he's gonna try to play in
the postseason and then all of a sudden
he's on the roster then all of a sudden
he's da Qing to start all of a sudden
he's contributing to the Chicago Cubs
who end up obviously winning the World
Series Kyle schwarber the Cubs joins us
here in the Dan Patrick show give me the
best thing that's happened let's say the
last five days to you I would say that
it was the Cubs parade I remember we
were up on stage doing you know getting
introduced and making sure you know
everyone got the recognition but I got
that when I got introduced I had to go
up and give a little speech and I looked
out and I was like holy cow you know
there you can't see the end of people
and for it to be like the seventh
largest gathering and the whole world
this tells you how much this meant to
the fans and we can't be more proud to
bring this back to Chicago I was looking
at the comments that Rizzo made that
Ross had to go out and kind of calm him
down he was having this out-of-body
experience what were you thinking in the
latter part you know as he went into
extra innings there in game seven my
mindset was was I was I felt like I was
in the right mindset obviously once that
home run was hit you know the guy was
bad and he did a really good job and you
know my mom was kind of shifting luckily
we had that rain delay where Jason gets
us all in the weight room and makes sure
he just wants to make sure that we're
all on the same page he wants us to know
that we're a good team we won 103 games
for a reason we faced adversity plenty
of times before you know there's no
there's no reason to change what we're
doing right now this this keep going
with the plan keep doing what we're
doing and we'll be fine
speech is gonna become legendary you
know that come yeah
you know they couldn't come from a more
perfect guy this guy grinded throughout
the whole year he was such an important
role on this team and you know that's a
guy that I want in there everyday he's a
great teammate you can't ask for a
better dude a grinder it was awesome if
we had to play a baseball game today
which one of your teammates would be in
the worst shape I would probably say Mia
Rossi me because I you know I have this
I'm living this great I love it
but Rossi is would probably be an
emotional wreck I can't imagine what
he's gone through the last last week
with you know him retiring him winning
the World Series him hitting a homer in
his last game of the World Series you
know this thing it was all over then
he's got to go play it again I think
that'd be pretty funny
and he's such a good dude too we're
talking to Kyle schwarber of the Cubs
joining us Dan Patrick show if you look
at this whole feeling that you have now
take me back to when you were going to
rehab after you blow out your knee and
how low did you did you get so deep down
inside my when I hurt myself you know I
was probably down for about two weeks no
one really saw it on me I wanted to you
know make sure I still had the the show
that I had the right mindset but it
really hit me stuck with me for two
weeks but once we had surgery it was
like okay let's go we we got through
it's time to start rehabbing times start
getting back and you know my doctor a TI
physical therapy you know these these
were these guys were big components and
my rehab and luckily a TI physical
therapy is a really big sponsor of the
Cubs you know we we as you know we did
this big renovation of the clubhouse and
they sponsored the you know the the
physical training room and it's it's so
huge now that
you know I don't feel like I'm getting
away people if I got hurt last year I
would have been in Arizona just doing
rehab and I probably wouldn't had the
opportunity that I that I had to play in
the World Series but you know in the
early stages of rehab it was it was
different whenever the team was home I
was doing at home in the clubhouse but
whenever they went on the road I'd have
to go to a TI physical therapy meet with
some some of their people and you know
this is this make sure that we're on the
same plan and they did a great job they
made sure that I stayed on the plan you
know grinded it out with me it was great
and then going on the later parts rehab
you know my teammates really really came
up big for me you know it never stays I
wasn't you know feeling it or just down
and these guys picked me up the fans
picked me up to this I remember it's
game like 102 and I'm getting tweets and
everything like that saying herbs would
be miss via wish you're out there you
know keep keep killing rehab it was just
you know a total team effort from
everyone to you know make sure that I
was doing good and then once I got to
the doctor's visit when we were in Game
three of the NLCS saying that I got
cleared it was you know there was a lot
of emotions there because it was a fella
gave us such a long journey I know that
there's people going through a lot worse
than what I went through and but for for
everyone to have this this team effort
to make sure that that I was in good
shape and mentally and physically
it meant a lot how did you keep it under
wraps that there was even even a remote
chance of playing in postseason
I really didn't think there was I'm not
gonna lie every time I went to my
doctor's meetings down in Dallas he he
always say you know we're looking at the
second half of winter ball maybe that's
the make sure that I get some at-bats
for going into spring training and then
once I like once I said I had that
doctor's visit at game 3 and it was
probably the best
possible news that could have got at
this it just shows you the the the rehab
that was done by ATI a physical therapy
the rehab that was done by the Cubs the
fans that my teammates my family my
girlfriend everything you know it this
showed that that that paid off a lot and
for me to get cleared there and I was
like man I just want a shot to do this
and I remember I texted Theo I said hey
can you give me a call he did and I said
hey this is this give me a shot and he
did I knew that there was no guarantees
but a lot of hard work paid off how
tough was it to go back to Wrigley and
not be able to play in the field it
wasn't tough obviously deep down I
wanted to because I wanted to help my
teammates in any way possible but me
being out in the field wouldn't be
helping my teammates at all you know I
just physically couldn't do it and you
know see there was a ball hit down the
line whatever it probably would have
been a triple and you know you you you
want to try to drive him more than you
give up but it just wouldn't I just
don't think it would be right for my
teammates if I was out there you realize
you never have to pay for a beer in
Chicago again I know it's perfect that's
ever Kyle that's like for your the rest
of your life you'll be 80 years old and
you walk into Murphy's and they'll go
schwarzkopf on over I got you it's been
it's so crazy you know this this city is
such a sports town and you know you're
only gonna find maybe 3 cities like that
that that people really do care about
their sports and you know Chicago is
completely different you're in the
Midwest and they're gonna they're going
to be with you through your ups and
downs and you know we can't thank them
enough for for what they've you know
been through and now what they're
enjoying
it's it's been so much fun for us in
them I'm sure well congrats Kyle and
good luck trying to follow this up with
an encore performance we appreciate you
joining us thank you Dan I appreciate it
Kyle schwarber Cubs outfielder he's he's
up there first team all bro I think he's
gonna be in my own field that's that's
for sure the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience